il s'appelle thomas 3 27 ans pas depuis
longtemps d'ailleurs une semelle et tué
la benjamine du comité directeur du
parti socialiste
tu étais extrêmement médiatisé pendant
les événements étudiants de la fac 86
mais on l'a surnommé isabelle la
catholique ce qui est assez drôle et
c'est pas pour rien parce que tu es
devenu star en quelques semaines les
yarmouth a mal tourné c'est quand tu as
fait cette photo dans paris match on t'a
vu alanguie sur un piano avec une coupe
de champagne c'était grand mas me
trouvais qu'il y un peu trop quoi c'est
mal coiffée à mon goût mais
pas du tout at on dit mais bon c'est
vrai que c'était un piège que m'avait
tendu hebdomadaire paris match je je
suis content on discute avec un jean
après ça semble se confirmer
et puis c'est vrai que je ne suis pas
une propre
il ya une phrase que tu a relevé dans
avec la déclaration de principes du
parti socialiste qui est à dire le parti
socialiste est un parti révolutionnaire
il ne peut pas exister de démocratie
réelle dans la société capitaliste est
ce qu'aujourd'hui tu souscrit encore à
cette déclaration de principes du parti
socialiste moi je regarde d'abord je
n'ai pas relevé trois qu'on a fait une
contribution à l'occasion du congrès
deal avec différentes à parade où on a
rappelé cette phrase et julien dray
on a rappelé cette phrase de la
déclaration principes du parti mais oui
je crois que moi je regarde notre
gendarme ou simplement et puis je suis
pas contente
ouais ça me satisfait pas jo ça nous met
mal à l'aise j'ai attendu justine de
drames chose qui est ce que tu assistes
jeu
à damas où c'est la mi temps
oui tu as comme un dogme et sa femme
quoi qu'en dise qui s'impose à nous
comme une bible mais comme une méthode
d'analysé comme je pense que tu as dit
aussi donc ça c'est toi qui l'a dit
c'est pas le parti socialiste le dit le
gaullisme c'est l'anti démocratie
je suis contre l'homme providentiel cela
pas faire plaisir mitterrand quand même
mais je crois que c'est un vrai débat
c'est un vrai débat parce que il est
vrai que
françois mitterrand est apparu notamment
que dans la campagne présidentielle un
peu quand même mais je crois que en
dehors de ses qualités propres
il y a que les institutions de la vème
république font que le président de la
république qui est le seul homme est à
cette place à cette position élu au
suffrage universel est avec
l'approbation la majorité de trouver
lectorat se trouve porté et comme tout
est contre le présidentielle sauf quand
il s'agit de mitterrand entend donc non
c'est pas ça
et ce même si en france donc je dis que
je suis contre l'improvisation par
principe je suis donc tout compris ce
soit aisément les autres comme fort mais
je ne
on peut pas porter la responsabilité a
forcé les grandes que je pense que ce
sont les institutions la vème république
qui fouillent amène à leçon avait mis
d'accord fin mai une autre affaire dont
on a parlé ces derniers temps c'est
cucul devait être chargé d'une mission
sur les jeunes et l'europe
j'avais des bureaux qui était réservé
que tu es tout près tu n'avais plus qu'à
s'installer
et puis tu vas être critiqué la gestion
sociale du gouvernement rocard et michel
rocard a mis son veto au fait que tu
diriges cette mission est à la baisse au
point et dans l'observateur c'est pas
très grasse par contre comme ça que ça
s'est passé
il est vrai que je devais avoir une
mission sur les jeunes au but et que je
ne les a eus avec eux que je ne suis pas
très contente qu'elle lui livre de
thierry pfister qui fait beaucoup de
souci pour toi qui pense que tu es
manipulés qui pense que tu es une jolie
fleur carnivores milieu des plantes
parasites
tu as lu tout ça costa york à partir du
moment où on est une femme on fait de la
politique il a peur des jolies bulles et
c'est pire que ça c'est forcément qu'on
est passé dans le lit d'un de ces
messieurs ça ne peut pas honnête
retrouve donc à partir de là vous serez
nar époux je vois souvent mitterrand
de temps en temps
dubois cette fois on discute politique
disent que c'est un individu qui sait
parler beaucoup de choses par exemple
tout fou de littérature de
deux spectacles de sculpture dernière
question s'il passait sous un camion ça
c'est inquiétant en il a aucune chance
moyens vite ça je sais pas j'ai pas
réfléchi à la question
mais de toute façon je ne pose pas le
problème je ne me pose pas les besoins
en terme d' individus j'ai vite en tout
cas je sais bien qu'il soit cadré à la
cour en or celikkol dans de toute façon
c'est sûr que ça serait pas le courant
intervient